salut les carrières
bienvenue dans votre samedi soir ces
entrepreneurs alors aujourd'hui s'il n'a
pas exceptionnel puisque nous sommes le
samedi 5 novembre 2044 et nous fêtons
les soixante quinze jours
invité d'honneur ce soir celle sur
laquelle le temps n'a aucune prise
arielle dombasle
ah ouais non mais là c'est quand même
assez impressionnant
vous êtes comme ya 30 ans ça me fait
plaisir excusez-moi également oui ça
vous fait quel âge et bien
va quand même à vous les faites pas me
fait est que c'est par tempérament j'ai
décidé de ne pas vieillir et j'y suis
arrivé autre invité ce soir canada
[Applaudissements]
makan koné seydou
ba ces mêmes qu'à l'époque mais en plus
long et avec un petit peu moins parfois
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
on est ravi que ce soir le président
d'honneur du parti populiste français
l'ex ministre de l'intérieur
stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir vous quittiez
déjà très méchant il ya 30 ans j'imagine
que ça ne s'est pas améliorée en
vieillissant oui je suis de plus en plus
méchant oui effectivement
j'adore
autre invité ce soir a évidemment celui
qui a créé cette émission qu'il ya dix
ans
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ses paroles je vois que les
auteurs n'ont pas changé depuis 30 ans
voilà une chose à l'époque et les
groupes ayant défendu
e
[Musique]
canada 2 rebonds soir bonsoir
alors qu'à la date vous êtes comédiens
et humoristes vous avez commencé votre
carrière en étant la star des ados
chapelle qui trop dur
ça pas été facile en même temps moi je
me rends compte que les jeunes ils
aiment toujours la même chose qu'à
l'époque en arrivant tout à l'heure au
studio y avait des il y avait des
petites filles avec des t-shirts one
direction et des petits vieux avec des
t-shirts one direction ils voulaient
juste une rixe juste une scène
à laquelle on se rappelle qu'en novembre
2014 lui sorti la première version
longue de votre série soda et là c'était
un triomphe sans précédent la plus forte
audience de m6 depuis l'époque où loana
faisait bouillir l'eau de la piscine war
vous êtes on dit ah ça évidemment ça a
été une belle surprise
on a fait cela prime après on a vendu
aux américains ils ont fait la version
américaine avec brad pitt et will smith
et s'applique encore à après ouais après
c'est gagner roland garros en double
mais tout seul ça c'était très agréable
aussi ouais donc voilà je suis très
heureux à chaque fois quand je vois
comment notre époque évolué je trouve
qu'on a tous des finalement des déplace
à trouver la joie vous avez récupéré
françois hollande dans le groupe de
musique je trouve ça génial
et là c'est le drame
[Musique]
tout s'est effondré quand on a découvert
que le soldat était dangereux pour la
santé la vente des boissons sucrées été
interdite en 2024 du coup moi ça m'a je
vais pas vous mentir ça m'a un peu tout
foutu en l'air mon fonds de commerce du
coup ce que j'ai fait c'est qu'on a créé
une nouvelle série qui s'appelait eau
minérale sans additif alors forcément
c'était moins drôle mais c'était plus à
quoi donc voilà on a été au bout du
délirant finalement parlez nous de la
scène qu'elle on se souvient qu'après le
one man show vous aviez en décembre 2014
fait le zénith de paris votre deuxième
spectacle voila voila on regarde un
extrait internet c'est mal sécurisés de
nos jours mais sur ce que les sites x
descamps sécuriser les sites x avez-vous
vraiment 18 ans oui
non
comme si mon frère est allé le dire je
peux pas mentir mon ordi
moi je dis que si on voulait vraiment
freiner l'accès des jeunes aux sites x
c'est pas des questions débiles qu'il
faudrait mettre des exercices de
grammaire
si vous voulez que c'était un porno
pommery ampère l'exercice ci dessous
retrouvez le groupe nominal soulignait
remplacez le par un complément et
indiquer la nature du complément
souligné
sinon si longtemps après nom traîné avec
un nouveau one man show tout à fait je
joue en ce moment mon nouveau spectacle
très inspiré de mon premier spectacle
qui s'appelle le young man show
maintenant ça s'appelle le young man
show que je jouerai très bientôt un peu
partout en tournée interstellaire vénus
saturne on va partout même dans les plus
petites planètes tout ce qui est plutôt
plus thoune tout ça on y va quoi
aujourd'hui
toute l'amérique vos enfants deviennent
comédiens comme vous alors en fait j'ai
qu'un seul enfant mon fils s'appelle
jeune brendon pikachu ipad adams c'est
un nom composé c'est sa mère qui a voulu
vous savez comment elle et angelina
jolie elle a un peu relou sur ce genre
de d'autres way du coup voilà moi je je
je veux pas que mes enfants que mon fils
en tout cas deviennent comiques après
c'est sûr que souvent les fils du
chanteur deviennent chanteurs souvent on
est inspiré par ce que parce que font
les parents aujourd'hui qu'elle adams
vous avez quitté la france vous vivez
sur vénus c'est pour des raisons
fiscales
pas tu pas que j'aime bien venus déjà
parce que ma nouvelle femme et
vénusienne et puis je veux pas vous
mentir n'y a rien de tel que de boire un
ptit cocktail d'iridium posée sur sa
navette spatiale tranquille petite pluie
d'astéroïdes
après on bouge souvent je veux un
week-end sur saturne ce cas beaucoup de
tournages sur saturne parce que souvent
et des attentions silence saturn
[Applaudissements]
et donc voilà après moi j'aime bien
aussi aller sur pluton j'aime bien aller
manger dès mars sur mars voilà c'est
tout ça c'est mais derrière tout ça et
ouais ouais vous me rappeler quelqu'un
que vous faites ça quand même un peu
les fans du genre bonsoir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
en 2010 son élection marine le pen vous
incite à vous lancer en politique en
2020 vous vous présenter aux municipales
à sèvres sous l'étiquette ps vous
devenez finalement si vous avez toujours
combattu stéphane oui je crois qu'au
fond de moi j'ai toujours été un
politique frustré ce qui expliquait ma
méchanceté sur scène une époque que je
regrette aujourd'hui
en 2025 après deux mandats d'un greipel
geoffroy didier devient président de la
république il vu l'homme ministre ancien
grand écart à vous passer de la gauche à
droite je crois que je froid didier sera
toujours moins de droite que manuel
balce
n'allait pas libération journal dans
lequel vous avez écrit titre à votre
sujet guillon buisson même combat
non maman s'était pas libération
libération a fait faillite en 2015 comme
vous le savez c'est aujourd'hui une
cafétéria je crois c'est le jdd qui a
écrit ça alors oui je n'ai dit un proche
du président dj et à l'elysée vous allez
croiser stéphane bern qui partage sa vie
depuis de nombreuses années ça s'est
passé comment dans votre travail
formidable je crois que stéphane bern et
une première dame de france exceptionnel
là
depuis
[Applaudissements]
depuis bernadette chirac je crois que il
ramène élégance française à l'étranger
de façon formidable il porte le tailleur
chanel comme personne ils ont adopté
geoffroy un petit à petit labrador c'est
un couple très attachant
en 2035 louis sarkozy a épousé l'une de
vos filles elle s'est passé comment la
noce t'as pas été trop dur de croiser
nicolas sarkozy et nicolas sarkozy s'est
beaucoup assagie depuis son séjour en
prison
c'est un homme qui pour la première fois
de sa vie a changé véritablement changé
stéphane est quelqu'un va chanter au
mariage
non comme vous le savez car là est
partie depuis des années avec le
petit-fils de mick jagger
c'est la cougar les plus célèbres de
grande bretagne
qu'elle n'était pas là
en 2039 l'ancien président françois
hollande des scènes à l'âge de 85 ans
whittier que deux à son enterrement vous
julie gayet valérie trierweiler une
autre de ses ex n'était même pas
présente au cimetière pensez quoi de son
attitude et valérie trierweiler été avec
le président du conseil italien avec le
président espagnol avec le président du
honduras
elle est aujourd'hui avec le président
des états unis il faut que les
présidents du monde entier se méfie de
valérie trierweiler
alors lorsqu'un célèbre julien proust le
fils de gaspard vous a violemment cassez
n'est pas gaspard qui veut n'est pas
gaspard proust qui veut et le talent
visiblement a sauté une génération voilà
gaspard père avait énormément de talent
julien dans la pas beaucoup et c'est
souvent le cas
et c'est souvent le cas chez les fils
d'humoriste
[Musique]
arielle dombasle re bonsoir rebond soir
alors allez on se disait qu'on avait 85
ans oui vous ne faites pas du tout car
henin c'est un choix mais oui c'est un
choix mais comment on fait il faut
bouger il faut nager et puis moi vous
savez je passe mes vacances en fin d'été
sur mercure et l'hiver j'aime saturn
ariel nous aussi continuer le cinéma
bien sûr ouais d'abord en tant
qu'actrice oui on se souvient de la
suite de litres de papa et la maman qui
s'intitulait les deux papa gay et les
trois mamans le
premier film qui parlait enfin les
problèmes de pma d'egp en france 1
ensuite il ya eu aussi pauline à la
plonge
pauline à la plage et puis évidemment
comment ne pas le citer le jour et la
nuit à saint tropez la suite tant
attendue du jour et la nuit mais bernard
amélie un beau souvenir
comme à berlin toujours secrétaire
général de l''onu malthus et il est
arrivé quand même à faire pas mal pour
la paix dans le monde ah ouais ça on lui
doit ça
[Applaudissements]
non c'est simplement
2044 ouais c'est un événement
exceptionnel en effet vous êtes ici ce
soit pour la ressortie au nouveau format
multi hd 5 des scan de votre film culte
opium c'est incroyable vie mesure jean
cocteau que vous aviez réalisé en 2013
mais est ce que vous pensiez que ce film
deviendra culte et bien je ne sais pas
au monde du tournage on m'avait dit à un
coup quelle audace de faire ce film
c'est génial et alors finalement culte
je savais pas que ça deviendrait aussi
culte mais je suis content parce que ça
y est le dvd ressort vu la demande et il
est là et ça ça me fait plaisir
alors ce qui m'a coûté la vie des gens
portent sur le tout début des années 20
quand il rencontre raymond radiguet au
coeur du paris intellectuel et mandat
vous allez raconte une histoire d'amour
contrariée éphémère qui se termine par
un mort de radigues et à 23 ans et la
fuite de cocteau dans l'opium trente ans
plus tard on penser qu'il sera enfin
compris ariel ho je crois oui oui parce
que d'abord on s'est aperçu à quel point
ce personnage jean cocteau qui avait été
tellement décriée et méchamment moqué
pendant sa vie est vraiment une figure
stellaire
irradiante qui traverse le temps on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble trente ans
après
le père
[Musique]
je soigne
[Applaudissements]
blessures
olé
une grande nouvelle
criant
[Musique]
c'est vraiment ça qui va
m ensuite bien sûr vous compléterez
votre trilogie après opium sur la vie de
jean cocteau vous ferez héroïne sur la
vie du saint laurent puis cocaïne sur
celle de john galliano
finalement à y habiter beaucoup un drame
non
mais nous aimons tous la drogue puisque
finalement elle nous permet quand même
facilement de passer de la vie à la mort
parce que sans la morphine ont rien
n'irait plus arielle dombasle
alors thierry ardisson re bonsoir
bonsoir jamie appelez-moi jean-michel je
suis plus votre assistant
d'accord thierry ardisson est là
messieurs
95 ans un bide apparemment
24 ans il les fait pas les 95 ans
alors tirez vous avez été le premier
animateur de cette mission alors que je
prenne notre place en 2021 ouais brawn
avait voulu tient un peu je t'avais tout
appris je me suis senti un petit peu
comme un ouvrier de chez renault con
qu'on remplace par un robot un coin un
ouvrier c'était un truc d'avant toit
n'était pas de jean-louis
alors tirez vous qui aviez fêter les 30
ans de kannad ici même en 2014 ça vous
fait quoi de voir que canal est toujours
là ça me fait énormément plaisir
évidemment salut les terriens un petit
jour là et puis ça lui les vénusiens
marche bien
salut les martiens aussi
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez quoi d'évolution la
télévision justement qu on coupe la
publicité par des émissions ça me choque
je me suis fait bien sûr mais ça
perturbe un peu parce qu' un certain
moment on oublie ce qu'on voulait
acheter
michel le gall est toujours là à 102 ans
c'est un modèle pour vous d'y aller
[Rires]
c'est sûr que quatre
c'est sûr que 80 ans de carrière cet
exceptionnel
maintenant on décongèle deux heures par
semaine pour faire son émission de
dimanche
c'est plus facile c'est sûr alors
thierry c'est vous qui avait inventé la
nuque et été ou dans cette émission vous
posez la même question la question qui
tue tété ou tiers dix ans
après mon remplacement par alessandra
sublet sur canal
et puis par vous un mois plus tard
je suis parti sur la chaîne numéro 23
j'ai fait une émission qui s'appelait
personne en parle qui traitait de
deux sujets dont personne
c'est un marché c'est un marché
personnes en a parlé
mais
[Applaudissements]
est aujourd'hui vous sentez comment a
bâti un peu chanteau rouillé la
wii et l'indien j'en ai
je crois qu'on peut le dire thierry vous
avez marqué l'histoire la télévision par
votre manière de dire ouais oui nous en
faire de ouais comme à la grande époque
ya longtemps que j'ai pas fait ça mais
bon je suis ici et pour vous ouais
[Applaudissements]
ouais tu vois son way convainc toujours
oui ariel et envie de pêcher de thierry
ardisson vieux un peu quand même hein ah
ouais ça voulait dire je vous écoute
chéri goût ça voulait dire j'écoute rien
je pense déjà à la question suivante
alors tirez vous avez la réputation de
bien protéger vos idées ya une dizaine
d'années d'ailleurs vous étiez fait un
procès à vous-même pour plagiat vous
étonnez pas trouvé un accord avec
lui-même nyan win
maintenant quand j'ai une idée je fais
moi-même un institut national de la
propriété intellectuelle pour voir si je
n'ai pas déjà déposé en fait
plus simple alors quel gros moment de
ces dernières années nous ont marqués
dien ben il ya eu
l'entrée de frédéric beigbeder à
l'académie française
cyril hanouna qui est devenu en 2027 le
conseiller culturel du président didier
et puis les funérailles nationales de
marine le pen en 2030
le problème c'est qu'elle était toujours
vivante
j'ai pris non seulement votre place mais
va être revoir but c'est sûr que quand
les animateurs ont été remplacés par des
robots
c'était certain un problème mais le pire
je trouve c'est quand les
téléspectateurs ont aussi été remplacés
par des robots
là j'imagine que vous avez lancé la pub
et oui mais pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux